good morning John in 2014 my social
media was suddenly inundated with people
telling me about and telling me to talk
about solar freaking roadways an
Indiegogo campaign that had been
published by a company that was making
roads that could good news solve every
problem because look America is
extremely paved there are so many roads
and so many parking lots and so many
more parking lots than you think there
are if we were placed all of the paved
area in the U.S with solar panels we
would produce more power than the US
uses which is a wild statistic that is
completely irrelevant the list of
reasons why solar roads are a bad idea
is very long I will put an incomplete
list on the screen right now I'll also
put some links in the description but
this video is not about why silver roads
are a bad idea it's about why so many
people thought they were a good idea in
medicine or on the podcast sawbones you
often hear that cure-alls cured nothing
the human body and all the things that
can go wrong with it are just too
complex for there to be some magical
simple solution that solves everything
and as I re-watched that 2014 solar
freaking roadways video the feeling I
get is that the list of problems being
solved is just too long they could
improve drainage enhance playgrounds
alert drivers to upcoming moose fixed
the economy eliminate the need for
fossil fuel melt snow Dick's power
transmission and make partying more fun
this is a video built to make people
excited about something and since the
average person doesn't know very much
about how roads work we have people for
that it's pretty easy to make a list of
problems and then propose a solution
that would solve all of them as long as
you don't look too hard or know too much
what this relies on is people not
understanding how complex something that
seems simple is and that's fine we're
not supposed to nor can we know about
everything I think this actually
outlines a really important tension in
society between like not wanting or
being able to have everyone understand
the intricacies of how tires interact
with different paved surfaces at
different levels of moisture and
temperatures and speeds and also being
frustrated by problems that we see and
we see not getting fixed and then of
course experts are annoyed when you're
like why don't you just fix this problem
and you're like well you don't want to
know how complicated it is you don't
want to know how tires work experts
don't want to explain to you why you
can't make highways out of glass but the
division of expertise is like the number
one thing that makes societies work but
that stops working when there is no
trust and stories of big Simple
Solutions once they aren't implemented
either rely on you realizing that it's
more complicated or thinking that
there's some super powerful cabal that's
preventing us from doing the simple
things which is why a lot of the times
conversation about big Simple Solutions
interfaces with conspiracy theory solar
roadways are a big simple solution and
I'm sorry but big Simple Solutions are
very rare because everything is very
complicated like soap may have been the
last big Simple Solution so they do
happen but it's been a while but
honestly the reason I think this was a
moment in a sort of Coney 2012 but two
years later kind of way was a good
impulse it was hopefulness like that was
a hopeful moment we felt like the
internet maybe could put an end to a
Ugandan warlord or maybe even create a
future where roads melted ice warned you
about moose and generated more
electricity than the cars that ran on
them used maybe the problems weren't
being solved because there wasn't enough
hope or human excitement this was a wild
time on the internet we did not know
what was possible if only we hadn't
found out the solar roadways people are
actually still at it they've done some
small scale installations and the way I
see it it is an incremental value add
for a very specific situations which get
this is fine it's how almost everything
gets done in this big messy complicated
world because the big problems aren't
there because evil people create them
they are there because 8 billion people
living together on a single planet is
difficult and those big problems only
ever really get solved in one situation
and that's when lots of people with
wildly varying areas of expertise trust
each other and work together to solve
them John I'll see you tomorrow